Ein Worst Bird Production True Crime Podcast. Ich stelle jetzt auf, was gerade passiert, woher komme ich, warum tut mir alles weh, wo sind meine Kopfhörer, ich bin dann aufgewacht auf dem Kisten im Kisten. Das ist mein Beitrag zu der gesamten Geschichte. Das war's? Das war's. Hä? Und damit geht es auch schon los zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Eine frische neue Packung wird aufgerissen. Mögt ihr nicht auch den Geruch dieser neuen Podcast-Folge? Ihr kennt ihn schon, aber jede Woche ist es ein bisschen neu und ihr riecht da auch ganz genau natürlich eine ganz markante Note raus. Genau, dieser beissende unangenehme Geruch, das ist, wenn ich, Florentin Will. Danke. Und quasi... Weirdly, habe ich dich jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ich bin zurückgerudert mitten im Satz, mit dem Witz, weil ich das so fies fand, wollte dann eigentlich mich selber ownen, hat dann aber deinen Namen gesagt und jetzt ist das ganz verwirrender Witz. Stefan, ich glaube, an den Selbstzweifeln merkt man schon, wie ich hier spricht und auf der anderen Seite natürlich der Kork der Podcast-Ufoszene von Rundchen Will. Ja genau, was ich geil finde, ist der beste Gork aller Zeiten, ist Tennisbälle. Tennisbälle sind sehr gut, obwohl sind es wirklich die Bälle ist es die Umluft? Es ist die frische. Die werden ja, es ist eine perfide Art Ball, weil da ist Luft drin, aber der entweicht ganz langsam. Das heißt, man muss irgendwann mal wieder frische Bälle haben und die werden halt sozusagen konserviert, indem sie verkauft werden in luftdichten Dosen. Und die haben vorne oben wie so eine Lasche, wie so eine Dose, dann machst du dann auf, dann schießt die Luft von außen rein und dann muss man so einen verheiligen, so einen fantastischen einmal einziehen. Und dann ist man ganz kurz in so einer ganz anderen Welt, wo viel Tennis gespielt wird. Die werden ja, glaube ich, in vier Vierern verkauft. Vierer. Ich frage mich nur, wie lange es gedauert hat, bis man sich auf diese magische Nummer geeinigt hat. Davor hat man 16 verkauft, sondern ewig lange Röhre. Eine Riesendose. Genau, Riesenlang. Und dann die Leute immer in der U-Bahn. Jumbo Schreiner sucht die grösste Tennisballdose. Ja genau, das war ein Problem. Wirst du mal gesagt, das ist albern, lass uns 10 machen. Und dann 10 immer noch so ein langes Teil zusammen in der U-Bahn mit den U-Bahn-ern und alles. Machen wir fünf oder machen wir zehn in einer ganz, ganz langen Lanze.
Ähnliche Diskussionen, die die Schokokussindustrie ja auch hatte.
Machen wir zweimal acht, machen wir einmal sechzehn oder machen wir vier mal vier?
Ist es billiger, ganz, ganz lange Kartons zu nehmen?
Ja, gute Frage.
Ich glaube schon.
Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich glaube, aktuell ist es zweimal neun.
Zweimal acht, zweimal sechs oder was ist in der Richtung. So oder so, vielen Dank an das Intro-Team. Viktoria, Leo, entweder ist das ihr voller Name oder ist es noch eine zweite Person namens Leo involviert. Viktoria und oder Leo, schön, dass ihr dieses Intro zusammengeschrieben habt. True Crime ist tatsächlich für uns so ein bisschen diese Intros oft, weil wir uns schlicht nicht erinnern können an alte Folgen. Das heißt, für uns ist es genauso spannend wie für neue Hörer. Was für ein Humorverbrechen haben wir denn da begangen? Wenn Stefan da seine witzige Anekdote von Wochenende erzählt, ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern, ich bin genauso wie ihr, klammer ich meine heisse Kaffeetasse zusammen vorm Kamin und frage mich, was erlebt der denn immer, was macht der denn so?
Und dann laufen diese Intros und unsere Augen werden
zu ganz kleinen Schlitzen und es wird sich
so nach vorne gebeugt, um genau zu hören,
was passiert. Das ist auch
eine komische Sache, man spitzt ja
die Sinne manchmal, wenn man auch nicht
so richtig, wenn man etwas mehr
sehen will, mehr erleben will oder
etwas nicht genau hört, etwas ist leise,
etwas ist weit weg und
man spitzt die Ohren, ist ja eher
diese Vergrösserungsgeste, man hält die Hand
Vielen Dank. wenn man mehr sehen will, mehr erleben will oder etwas nicht genau hört, etwas ist leise, etwas ist weit weg und man spitzt die Ohren, ist ja eher diese Vergrösserungsgeste, man hält die Hand ans Ohr. Oder die richten sich so aus. Oder man lehnt sich so rein oder Hunde richten die so aus oder Pferde, die manchmal im Gespräch, wenn ich mit den Pferden rede, ist super unangenehm. Okay, das ist ein gutes Gespräch, wenn er plötzlich jetzt fokussiert. Und dann bin ich in die Augen so, wenn erst das eine weg geht, so, wenn denkt, hä, das ist doch super spannend, wie ich dir gerade erzähle, dass die Immobilienpreise immer auch sich am Leitzins orientieren, ist ja auch super interessant für dich und dann, hä, dieses eine Ohr ist weg, aber eins ist noch da, findest du es halb spannend oder hast du da gerade eine Gefahr, okay, er ist raus, Pferd ist raus, das finde ich gut. Hunde auch, gleiche Prinzip? Finde ich auch gut. Ich mag aber auch, wenn man die Ohren spitzt, wie man sich hart auf ein Ohr committet. Da zeigt sich wirklich, welchem Ohr man am meisten vertraut. Indem man sagt, du, rechtes Ohr, du machst mal kurz Pause, wir schicken mal das gesamte Blut des Körpers ins linke Ohr. In der Zeitlupe, was hast du gesagt? Das eine Ohr wird nach hinten geschoben, der Kopf dreht sich, der ganze Körper dreht sich und man entscheidet sich fürs linke Ohr und das linke Ohr denkt sich jedes Mal so, that's a win team, that's a win. Team Order einfach, Team links. Und das rechte Ohr denkt sich immer, ich mach's fürs Team. Ich würde gerne auch mal vorne sein, ich würde gerne auch mal aufs Podium, aber ich mach's fürs Team. Hauptsache das Team kommt voran. Abends wird ein Bier getrunken und dann so, na, Team rechts, hat wohl nicht geklappt heute, oder? Da waren wir wohl ein bisschen hinterher. Ja, es ist keine Ahnung, aber irgendwie glaube ich, ist das Vertrauen noch nicht da. Also ich glaube, wenn wir uns mal beweisen könnten, würden wir gute Resultate... Hinsultat ... Ohren weg, Ohren weg, ich glaube. Aber ich stelle mir bei den Ohren auch immer vor, weil ich mag dieses, Augen zu kneifen, wenn man was genau sehen will, auch spannend. Darauf wollte ich gerade hinaus. Das ist kontraintuitiv, weil alle anderen Sachen bilden, also machst du grösser oder so, oder wenn du lauter sprichst, machst du den Mund weiter auf. Wenn du mehr schmecken willst, machst Mund auf. Nee, aber dann macht man eher mehr. Man macht eher immer mehr, um mehr zu fühlen. Ja. Oder mehr die Sinne wahrzunehmen. Und bei den Augen ist es genau das Gegenteil. Du guckst etwas in der Ferne und was du machst das Auge eher weiter zu. Das ist eine Fokussierung, ja. Ja, das hätte ich nicht mehr. Das ist ja eh die Frage, ob man mehr Sinne hat oder ob man die nur mehr fokussiert. Ich stelle mir aber bei den Ohren auch vor, dass das Ohr auch sich so zukneift.
Jetzt wollen wir mal genau gucken, was da los ist.
Wenn man genau riecht, jetzt wollen wir mal schauen, was genau das ist.
Ich stelle es mir ein bisschen vor wie so ein Teleskop, was wenn du das ausfährst, um weiter zu gucken, wird es ja auch eher quasi so gefühlt kleiner.
Wenn man sich so ein Jack-Sparrow-artiges Teleskop vorstellt, was ja erst so ein dickes, schlauchiges Röhrchen ist und dann zieht es ja raus, wird ja immer kleiner hinten raus, aber dadurch siehst du mehr. So stelle ich mir die Augen vor, wie sie funktionieren. So eine Verlängerung macht wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig Sinn. Die Optiker da draußen, Optikerinnen, werden es besser wissen. Wäre es natürlich auch besser, weil es sind die Zahnärzte. Die wissen besser, wie man mit Augen zukneift. Diese Überleitung möchte ich mir kurz doch mal auf dem Schreibtisch in Ruhe angucken. Der Zahnarzt, ich lege sie dir vor und dann kannst du nochmal drüber gehen, anstreichen, aber Zahnärzte wissen natürlich, wie man Zähne spitzt. Wie man weiß, jetzt geht es los. Ich war auch ein Zahnarzt. Und uns haben nämlich Zahnärzte korrigiert. Du hast natürlich relativ harte Worte gewählt. Du hast gesagt, niemals montags früh zum Zahnarzt gehen, da ist das alte abgestandene Wochenendwasser noch in den Leitungen. Genau, ich möchte mich entschuldigen für das Wort die Sauschweine. Ja. Ich habe gesagt, diese Sauschweine machen montags die Leitungen nicht auf, so dass ihr das abgestandene Restwasser bekommt. Genau, stellt sich raus, ich habe einige Nachrichten bekommen von Leuten, die um ihr gesamtes Lebensmodell bangen, die Angst haben, dass die Montagmorgenskunden wegfallen. Und da meinte einer sogar, nee, es ist sogar andersrum, denn übers Wochenende werden die Leitungen mit Desinfektionsmittel zugeballert, die dann übers Wochenende, haben Zeit, wir haben zwei Tage Zeit. Und dann kriegst du einfach Montagmorgen einfach so Ethanol, ein hundertprozentiges Ethanol. Ethanol mit gelöstem Schmutz und Bakterien. Kriegt der so direkt rein und dann meint er, nee, es ist sogar am besten, montags morgens zu gehen. Was macht denn mit den Leitungen dazwischen? Nicht jeder Zahnarzt macht das. Nee, genau, ich habe auch viele Nachrichten bekommen, es ist tatsächlich so, Wasser steht ab und dann wird es gefährlich, aber sie machen das gut, sie sind sich dessen bewusst und es wurde mir auch gesagt, das machen nicht alle. Aber Leute, die geschrieben hatten, in den Praxen wird das wohl gemacht, es wird entweder sogar externes Wasser bezogen, also gar nicht irgendwie aus eigenem Land. Habe ich gar nicht verstanden, wie das funktioniert, aber so externe Sachen, wo die eh immer durchlaufen und dann kriegen die, sind die gar nicht ans Wasseranschluss. Was heißt externes Wasser? Ich habe gar nicht verstanden. Ich habe es nicht hinterfragt. Es gibt nochmal so eine zweite Leitung neben der Hauptleitung, wo nochmal so das Premiumwasser, wo du so zwölf Euro im Monat zahlen musst und dann hast du Zugriff auf externes Wasser. Ja, oder die haben so einen eigenen Boden, so ein eigenes Fundus an Wasser. So ein Wassergenerator, wenn die Hauptleitung mal ausfällt, können die noch den Dieselwassergenerator anschmeissen und dann kommt nochmal extra externes Wasser rein. Ganz habe ich es auch nicht verstanden, jedenfalls haben die das nicht das Problem, dass das irgendwie nicht bewegt wird über die Nacht oder das Wochenende. Wir sind jetzt also vor der verwirrenden Situation, dass manche Ärzte montags morgens besonders gutes Wasser haben, andere, die das nicht machen, besonders schlechtes Wasser. Genau, wo alle immer gleichbleibend gutes Wasser haben, ist so ein schöner Donnerstag. Schöner Donnerstag. Schöner Mittwoch. Ja, die Leitungen sind warm, da wurde schon gut was rein und raus gepumpt. Genau, richtig. Da macht ihr nichts falsch. Selber ist man da ja auch am leistungsfähigsten. Wenn man selber am leistungsfähigsten ist in der Woche, geht zum Zahnarzt. Donnerstag ist dein Spitzentag. Ja, Montag morgens bist du ja zum Beispiel zum Nichts zu gebrauchen. Das stimmt, ja. Wie so ein Lappen einfach, wie so ein kompletter Lappen. Wir sind alle Lappen. Ich bin wie so ein Tennisball, der schon drei Jahre über den Kord geballert wurde. Der schon drei Jahre einem Hund gehört hat. Die Luft entweicht, einfach so die Luft entweicht, nichts von dem Originalgeruch ist noch da, man nimmt Dreck auf bei jeder Bodenberührung. Genau, Asche, Asche, jedes Mal voll geascht einfach. Das Logo ist so abgeknibbelt, das ist dann nicht mehr so, man erkennt nicht mehr, was so eine Brand das war. Ja. Ja genau, Montags ist man nicht da, aber so Mittwochs ist man dann am Start und so, dann kommt ja auch bald das Wochenende, man hat nochmal so den Drive, diesen Licht am Ende des Tunnels Drive und ich glaube, da sollte man einfach zum Zahnarzt gehen. Da sind die Leitungen nämlich auch am Start. Da kannst du am besten performen, weil es ist ja auch eine beidseitige Sache. Zahnarzt ist ja immer geben und nehmen. Ich habe das Gefühl, Zahnarzt ist ja immer eine kooperative Sache. Also du kannst ja auch selber den Zahnarztbesuch versauen. Oder zu etwas ganz Besonderem machen. Wenn du einfach alles runterschluckst, was dir in den Mund steckt, also von den Spiegeln bis zu den Bohrern, ich schluck alles runter. Mein ganzes Leben habe ich gelernt, was in den Mund kommt, wird geschluckt, einfach alles weg und jetzt plötzlich heißt es ne bitte. Ist das ein Merchprodukt von uns, was in den Mund kommt, wird geschluckt, ist das was? Wer es in den Mund nimmt, muss auch schlucken, so ein Sprichwort. So ein Dreni-Sprichwort, der Asag muss auch B sagen. Unser weniger schmissigeres Sprichwort vom Podcast UFO. Und jetzt plötzlich muss ich kooperieren und muss das so im Mund halten und das ist schwierig. Ich habe einfach den Reflex, selbst 10.000 Euro Instrumente einfach wegzuschlucken. Ich habe jetzt auch beim Zahnarzt für eine Kontrolle, die jährliche Kontrolle, gehe ich mit meinem kleinen Bonusheftchen hin, da wird immer noch ein Stempel reingemacht. Ich glaube, das machen die gar nicht mehr, es wird gar nicht mehr benötigt, aber die finden das irgendwie süß, dass ich bei dem blümlichen Rucksack mit meinem Stempelheftchen ankomme. Und dann machen die das noch und tun dann auch so, als würden sie stempeln. Es war alles komisch. Und dann essen auch alle Luft. Alles wird so für Kinder, wie man das für Kinder macht. Wenn man mit Kindern abhängt, die denken doch auch, als ob die das nicht checken. Kinder können ja Dinge machen und trotzdem dann isst man.
so ist auch keine egal du musst auch mitessen ja genau so und dann machen die
Stämpelchen rein und dann habe ich eine Kontrollentersuchung gehabt
und so eine Zahnreinigung war richtig
richtig cool, ein richtig kleines
cooles Event, hab da richtig Spass
dran und dann habe ich jetzt
ich habe seit ein paar Jahren
oder seit einem Jahr so eine
elektronische Zahnbürste, so eine elektrische, die dir alles wegflext. Und davor hatte ich immer eine manuelle. Und dann kommst du zur Zahnreinigung und dann kriegst du am Anfang, werden deine Zähne gefärbt. Und dann siehst du genau, wo noch der ganze Dreck dran ist, den du nicht mehr spürst, den man auch nicht wirklich sieht, aber du siehst noch, wo so Belag am Start ist. Dargestellt durch die wahrscheinlich schmutzigste Farbe Lila. Lila. Es sieht fast schöner aus, je dreckiger deine... Ja, meinst du? Ja, wunderschön. Und dann war nichts zu sehen. Seitdem ich die... Weil damals mit der manuellen Zahnbürste war... Also es war alles noch... Es war so ein Grundlilaton war am Start und natürlich die Zwischenräume besonders. Bei der elektrischen Zahnbürste, seitdem ich die benutzte, alles weg, nur in den Zwischenräumen so ein bisschen und dann hat sie gesagt, oh, aber sie müssen bei den Zwischenräumen echt aufpassen. Ich dachte mir, das war doch perfekt. Dann habe ich gesagt, Hand aus meinem Mund, Entschuldigung, das war ...
Schluck die Hand runter.
Schluck die Zahnärzte einfach komplett runter, das ist mein, wenn da negatives Feedback kommt, dann sage ich jetzt das nächste Mal, wenn du den Finger in mich reinschiebst, schluck dich komplett runter. Wir sagen ja auch immer, nicht schlucken. Und man denkt, damit man irgendwie nicht diese Substanzen, nein, damit man die nicht verschluckt.
Ich meine, was glaubt ihr denn, wo in der Zeitung diese toten Annoncen für die ganzen Zahnärzte kommen, die geschluckt wurden? Irgendjemand muss die schlucken. Jede Woche verlieren wir tapfere Zahnärztinnen und Zahnärzte, die einfach geschluckt werden. Die sind einfach weg. Ja, tut mir leid, wir können ihren Termin jetzt nicht wahrnehmen. Die Zahnärztin wurde geschluckt, die ist weg. Wie, die ist weg? Die ist geschluckt. Und Sie können nicht mehr helfen, den Termin wahrzunehmen? Nee, kann ich leider nicht machen, tut mir leid. Kommt sie mir. Weg, weg. Problem, geschluckt. Ja, so Praxis, so werden Praxen auch übernommen. Also wenn auch fremde externe Zahnärzte reinkommen, die dann sagen, ah, ich lasse mich mal behandeln, und dann schlucken die die bestehenden Zahnärzte weg und dann übernehmen die selber die Praxis. Das ist so wie Game of Thrones, wo dann so eine ganze Stadt langsam geschluckt wird. Wie schluckt man genau?
Schluckmuskeln im Hals. Ich habe ja lange Zeit so Wettesser verfolgt. Persönlich verfolgt. Du bist mit deinem Ford Fiesta. Du bist mit deinem Ford Fiesta. Du bist mit deinem Ford Fiesta. Du bist mit deinem Ford F wie die leben. Mit meinem Harlekin Fort K stand ich auf der anderen Seite der Straße und habe beobachtet. Und der meinte, der muss auch wirklich Schlucken üben, dass du viel Essen schnell schluckst. Und was der macht, ist, der nimmt sich immer so eine Wasserflasche und trinkt die mit so wenig Zügen, wie es geht, aus. Also möglichst grosse Schlucke und zählt, wie viel Schlucke. Und dann versucht er es am nächsten Tag mit weniger. So dass er irgendwann so eine ganze Wasserflasche mit so vier Schluck einfach wegballern kann. Und da werden Muskeln trainiert. Welche genau, weiss man nicht. Aber sie sind da. Sind die dann sichtbar? Der kann ja auch so anspannen. Das ist wie so ein Sixpack am Hals einfach nur so. Der kann dann so richtig posen. Heiko hat den schönsten Hals. Wäre eigentlich besser, weil wenn du einen Oberkörper hast, musst du dir immer irgendwelche Gründe ausdenken, warum du jetzt dein T-Shirt ausziehst in der Öffentlichkeit. Der Hals ist meistens frei. Der Hals ist meistens frei. Ja, deswegen auch diese Gesichtsmuskeln müsste man. Genau, die du immer flexen kannst. Aber weil du gerade gesagt hast von wegen, man muss bei Kindern Luft essen. Man muss eine Menge Luft, das ist das größte Problem, man muss eine Menge Luft essen. Ich habe ja lange mit Kindern zusammengearbeitet in meinem Zivildienst. Und ich weiß noch. Du hast die ruiniert. Ich habe viele davon ruiniert, körperlich, aber auch psychisch vor allem. Und weil du weißt ja auch nie, wann die Bullshit erzählen und was nicht. Wann nicht so. Dann kommt dann so ein Mädchen und sagt, ja, ich lade dich zum Kuchenessen ein und du sagst, ja, okay, dann komme ich mal bei dir vorbei und dann machst du weiterhin ein normales Zeug und eine Stunde später kommt sie und sagt, ja, wo bist du denn, der Kuchen ist fertig. Und ich dachte, ach so, jetzt, jetzt lädst du mich, okay, okay, wir haben keine Zeit, Eikarl, so, okay. Und dann war ich, da denke ich bis heute noch dran und dann war ich bei ihr beim Kuchenessen und dann hatte sie halt so ihr Service aufgebaut und alles so und dann hat sie Kuchen gemacht. Übrigens ein super, also das ist Service, das würde ich meinen Gästen nicht vorlegen. Altmodisch. Ja, das stimmt, aber das ist noch wichtig. Und dann bringt sie so den Kuchen, also Luft-Fantasierkuchen auf so einem Teller raus und dann gibt sie mir ein Stück und gibt sich ein Stück und dann isst sie ihr Stück, verzieht das Gesicht und sagt, na, der ist nicht gut. Oh, oh, nice. Nimmt die Kuchenplatte und wirft sie in den Müll. In den Müll? Ja. Die Mitte im Service? In den Luftmüll? In den echten Müll. In den echten Müll. Und das Papiergeschirr ... Also das war dann für mich die vierte Wand gebrochen. Ja, und das Geschirr muss ja auch mitspielen, weil das Geschirr, auf dem nichts ist, findet sich selbst wieder im Mülleimer, in einem echten Mülleimer. Aber die ist noch im Charakter, also der Teller ist noch im Charakter und sagt, ich bin nicht wirklich im Müll. Nee, ich glaube, es ist nicht mehr im Charakter. Es merkt, es ist im Müll für etwas, für einen Kuchen, was es nicht für einen Luftkuchen, der ausgedacht ist. Alles daran ist merkwürdig. Aber ich fand es so geil, dieses Mädchen hat in der Fantasie einen Kuchen gebacken, mich zum Kuchenessen eingeladen, ihren eigenen Luftkuchen probiert und gesagt, der schmeckt nicht und wirft ihn weg. Und dann war ja die Situation, sie hatte ihr Stück plus den gesamten Kuchen weggeworfen, ich hatte aber mein Stück noch auf meinem Teller. Und dann dachte ich, erwartet sie jetzt, dass ich auch sage, der schmeckt nicht gut? Oder muss ich jetzt sagen, nee, der ist doch super. Was genau passiert hier gerade? Yes and. Yes and das.
Aber was ist Yes, And? Soll ich Yes, And ihr Selbstbewusstsein zusprechen?
Yes, And ist nicht, ich finde den mega. Sie sind den weggeworfen gerade. Ja gut, aber du brauchst auch gewisse Konflikte, du musst ja auch den Plot am Laufen halten.
Wenn du jetzt auch sagst, ja du hast recht, der ist schlecht, bestellen wir was, gehen wir zu Becker Hessbacher und holen da einen Kuchen. Du musst ja den Konflikt laufen lassen so. Ich finde es gut, so ein hyperrealistisches Kinder-Date, so ein, du bekommst gerne, komm, komm gerne vorbei. Ich lade dich ein auf den Kuchen. Okay, ja klar. Okay. Hallo. Hi, komm doch rein. Oh, ich habe gerade frisch gewischt, ist noch ein bisschen nass, also wenn du die Schuhe irgendwie ausziehen könntest. Ach so, ja klar, okay, kein Problem. Ah, der Kuchen riecht ja schon lecker. Und Problem ist, ich habe noch Besuch von meiner Schwiegermutter, die ist jetzt irgendwie noch da, ja genau, die sitzt da jetzt noch rum. Sorry, ich konnte es nicht anders planen, ich konnte es nicht anders planen, irgendwie.
Okay, du kannst ja sagen, was riecht denn hier so angebrannt,
ach nein, jetzt habe ich den Kuchen,
was,
der sieht doch gut,
er ist komplett schwarz, okay, ja,
stimmt, stimmt, er ist völlig schwarz,
ja, du hast recht, es klappt aber auch gar nichts,
ich habe ja noch Fuck gesagt,
es geht aber auch alles daneben,
ach man, ich weiß auch nicht,
ist doch kein Problem, au, jetzt habe ich mich auch noch an diesem Kaktus geschnitten. Oh, der Kaktus steht aber ungünstig da jetzt genau da. Ja, er steht mitten im Raum, alles voller Kaktin. Scheiße. Was soll man ja auch nicht sagen? Wollen wir noch mal auf deinem Pferd reiten vielleicht die letzte Woche? Er ist gestorben. Was? Es tut mir leid, dass es noch hier im Wohnzimmer rumliegt.
Egon ist gestorben.
Egon hat sich
Egon hat, ja ich musste Egon erschießen,
weil Egon hat sich in einem Kind
verfangen, verbissen.
Und die Frage war, mussten wir das,
sollen wir das Kind anschläfern
oder das Pferd?
Weil so geht es nicht weiter. Die sind so ineinander verkehlt. Scheiße! Ich weiß nicht, was ich tun soll. Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam! Und dann war beide tot die beste Alternative. Julia, ganz kurz, Spielstopp. Du weißt, das ist deine Fantasie, du kannst machen, was du willst. Das läuft doch super bis leer. Ja, geht's aber bis jetzt, haben wir nur schlechte Nachrichten. Okay, egal, alles klar, gut, okay. Deswegen sorry, dass Egon hier einfach noch rumliegt und so. Der Kopf ist auch so komisch so aufgeklappt, ich weiß. Okay, wollen wir ihn zusammen rausbringen vielleicht, wenn ich jetzt schon mal da bin? Ja, okay, komm, wir heben den kurz hoch. Also wenn du die Hinterbeine nehmen könntest und so. Ja, kein Problem. Okay, ich nehme vorne den Kopf. Okay, Achtung, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hop muss ablesen, ich muss ablesen, viel zu schwer, viel zu schwer. Oh Gott, oh nein, es läuft auch noch, es läuft hier alles irgendwie, supp das aus seinem Kopf hier so, auf den guten Teppich. Das war ein Erbstück. Komm, wir können. Das war ein Erbstück von meiner Urgrossmutter. Sie hat Selbstmord begangen. Wirklich? Ja, es war furchtbar, es war furchtbar, setze ich vor meinen Augen eine Kuchengabel in die... Die Kuchengabel, mit der ich gegessen habe? Ja. Ja, also, ich meine, es geht. Ja, es ist viel Fantasie da, nur halt irgendwie in eine falsche Richtung. Aber das ist ja... Man muss echt aufpassen, dass man, weil man hat das ja auch selber in der Hand, seine Gedanken. Ja. Und man muss dann nicht also deswegen schau da an deine eine ruinierte Person. Ich frage mich, wo sie heute ist, falls sie zuhört, du kannst dir mal Feedback geben, ob ich richtig gehandelt habe oder nicht, weil ich habe dann in meiner Naivität gesagt, ach, ich finde Kuchen aber richtig gut und sie so, ne. Und dann war er aber vorbei. Vielleicht wollte sie ja über das Gespräch beenden, vielleicht wollte sie das unangenehme Treffen beenden. Ich glaube, vielleicht wollte sie mich dafür bestrafen, dass ich eine Stunde zu spät kam, dass sie dann sagt, nee, dann ist jetzt der Kuchen zumindest nicht gut. Eine reale Stunde? Ja, ja, eine reale Stunde, das war schon real. Das ist schon spät. Ich wusste nicht, dass sie das jetzt akut meint. Es war so ein Gespräch, wenn du sagst so, wenn Stefan, wir müssen auch mal wieder weggehen, oder? Ja, klar, voll. Alles klar. Machen wir auf jeden Fall mal. Hau rein, schau, schau. Und eine Stunde später kriegst du eine Nachricht, wo bist du? Oh mein Gott, übergreppig. Ich warte hier, so, was? Das war für jetzt eine Verabredung?
Es war natürlich auch so spannend. Ich habe, wie kriege ich das jetzt erzählt, ohne dass Leute sich wieder...
Ein politischer...
Ich war verabredet mit einer Gruppe und ich wusste, dieser eine Mensch kommt nicht.
Ich wusste das. Er hat da keine Lust, er kannte niemand anderen und so und ich wusste auch, der Weg ist zu weit und diese Gruppe in der Konzentration kommt zusammen, das ist eigentlich lustig, aber ich wusste genau, er ist zu weit weg. Er hat uns zwar schon zugesagt, er kennt dann auch niemanden, ich wusste, er wird absagen, das war auch völlig okay.
Und an dem Tag, er hat bis dahin nicht abgesagt, an dem Tag schreibt er mir dann, ich bin heute mit Zahnschmerzen aufgewacht. Und dann kriegt man so einen Riesenabsatz über Ibuprofen, blablabla, mir geht's nicht so gut, Zahnfressen bekommen, gestern schon beim Arzt gewesen, oh nein, und solche Sachen. Und dann von mir kriegt er auch einen Riesenabsatz, oh nein, gute Besserung, versuchst du es doch noch hiermit, ah, wenn du noch was brauchst, keine Ahnung, blablabla, und halt so auch einen Riesenabsatz Oh nein, gute Besserung, versuchst du es doch noch hier mit, wenn du noch was brauchst, keine Ahnung, bla bla bla, und halt so eine, auch einen Riesenabsatz. Und es ist ein reines Rumgebullschitte, was die Beziehung am Leben hält. Ja. Es ist so interessant, wie man, wie alle Beteiligten, ich glaube, es ist super häufig der Fall, alle Beteiligten in der Kette wissen, dass gerade gelogen wird. Ja. Und es ist so interessant, wie Menschen funktionieren. Aber man muss es noch aufrechterhalten, ja.
Weil Tiere zum Beispiel sind ja immer so mega
eins zu eins. Menschen
sind so wenig eins zu eins.
Eher eins zu zwei.
Was ist das Gegenteil? Also sehr...
Ja, also sechs zu eins, glaube ich,
ist so die normale. Ist das Entferndeste.
Also der tatsächliche Inhalt des Textes
ist eins, aber der geschriebene
Text ist das sechsfache.
Also anstatt ich komme nicht, weil ich keinen Bock habe, schreibst du sechs Sätze, ja, ich muss jetzt eh noch gucken, weil meine Schwiegermutter hat ja jetzt mit ihrem, da muss ich jetzt bei so einer Charity-Aktion, weil da machen die so irgendwie Müll sammeln und für jeden Kubikmeter gesammelten Müll kriegt eine Person Rollstuhl. Und jetzt haben die mich angerufen, dass sie noch nicht ganz einen Kubikmeter haben, sondern erst siebenhundert Kubikdezimeter. Dezikubik. Und man braucht ja insgesamt tausend Kubik. Du machst es dir aber auch selber schwer. Also du rennst selber in diese Einbahnstrassen. Da muss noch mal ein neues Tab aufgeben. Nochmal, wie viele Kubikdezimeter, weil die haben jetzt erst 700 Kubikdezimeter Müll für diese Charity-Aktion. Ich kann mir nicht so gut vorstellen, was du sagst. Und meine Schwiegermutter braucht einen neuen Rollstuhl. Und deswegen, also ich wäre mega gerne mitgegangen, im Wasserpark mit euch, aber ich kann leider nicht, ich muss noch Müll sein. Wir wissen alle, dass du nicht schwimmen kannst. Nein, nein, doch, doch, doch, klar. Wir wissen das alle, wir können das ewig lang schon. Ich kann, also klar, ich meine, hallo, wenn ich schwimmen könnte, soll ich jetzt hier in diesen See reinspringen, um euch zu beweisen? Nee, wie gesagt, musst du gar nicht. Also es ist doch albern. Sag doch einfach, du kommst nicht mit, weil du nicht schwimmen kannst. Ich meine, da ist auch Müll im See, dann könnte ich, aber das ist doch Quatsch. Das ist jetzt völlig ja Quatsch. Nein, brauchst du nicht. Das ist doch wirklich Quatsch. Nee, du brauchst es nicht. Alles gut. Hey, hey. Man lügt nicht,
habe ich gelernt,
aber so kommt man auch nicht durchs Leben.
Man muss lügen,
um Beziehungen aufrecht zu erhalten.
Und ich finde es super spannend. Man sollte eigentlich sagen, nee, pass auf, ich habe keinen Bock.
Ich habe keine Lust.
Und eigentlich hat das auch was Schönes,
wenn jemand einfach sagen kann,
pass auf, ich habe einfach gerade keine Lust.
Das zeigt doch eigentlich wirkliche Freundschaft. Ich finde unsere Beziehung so gegeben, dass ich einfach sage, nee, auf diesem konkreten Anlass, mein lieber Freund, habe ich einfach gar keine Lust. Und ich glaube, du würdest es machen. Bei mir, wenn ich dich irgendwo einlagen würde, du würdest sagen, pass auf, ich habe keinen Bock. Ich möchte, es liegt an dir, nicht an mir. Ich habe auf dich keine Lust. Wie gesagt, ich würde mit jeder anderen Person gerne in den Wasserpark gehen. Ansonsten, ich schaue mir Oppenheimer alleine an, lieber alleine als mit dir, Stefan. Okay. Okay? Der Plan war ja eigentlich, dass die Beziehung währenddessen nicht zu Schaden kommt. Genau. Deswegen dachte ich gerade, es ist schön, wenn du sagst. Ich mache lieber gar nichts, als mit dir ins Kino zu gehen. Ich sitze lieber zu Hause rum, ohne Internet, ohne Strom. Das ist nicht... Weil ich wirklich... Also du ziehst mich so runter. Die Zeit mit dir ist wirklich wie so eine Negativzeit, wo ich das Gefühl habe, nicht nur ist die Zeit... Pass auf, nicht nur ist die Zeit verschwendet, die ich mit dir verbringe, sondern ich habe das Gefühl, sie wird dann nochmal negativ auf meine Lebenszeit angewendet. Also sozusagen, als würde ich mich, pass auf, stell es dir so vor,
als würde ich mich in der Zeit, die ich mit dir verbringe, rückwärts durch die Zeit bewegen, die dann einfach gelöscht ist und die ich so doppelt
nie wiederkriege, verstehst du? Gut, dann kommen wir nicht zur Hochzeit.
Jeder Tag mit dir ist wie eine verschwendete Woche.
Oh, wow, das ist nice. So, du hast gesagt, ich soll ehrlich sein. Du hast gesagt, ich soll ehrlich sein, also bin ich ehrlich. Oppenheimer. Wohl eher Floppenheimer. Oh nee, eher gar nicht, es macht gar keinen Sinn. Super erfolgreicher Film. Bin ich nicht damit beschäftigt. Alles gebrochen, alle Rekorde gebrochen. Nein, weiß ich auch nicht, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber schon viele haben den gesehen. Dein Verdict, Florentins Kinoecke. Mein Verdict, ich war im Kino und saß neben einer Gruppe junger Damen, so sagen wir mal so 15, 16. Die eigentlich in Barbie wollten. Die entweder Teil des Barbenheimers Ding war, weil die haben sich auch den gesamten Film unterhalten, aber auch auf eine Art, wo ich dachte, diese Art von Unterhaltung passt nicht zu dem, was wir gerade sehen. Wir sehen gerade irgendwie, ja, sollen wir Wasserstoffbombe, ja oder nein, und die und ich denke mir so, also entweder sind es harte Physik-Nerds, die einfach so, Wasserstoffbombe, also mit dem angereicherten Plutonium wird das ja so nicht klappen. Also sowas muss ja alles gar nicht haben. Also sowas wirklich nicht. Aber ansonsten, ja, für mich. Ja, vor mir sass in einer Reihe vor mir die ganze Zeit jemand am Handy und hat, was ja eh schon mal nicht geht, was noch weniger geht, ist den Wikipedia-Artikel von Oppenheimer aufgehakt. Ach geil. Die ganze Zeit war ab Minute drei. Das finde ich ehrlich, dass er bereit ist, dem gesamten Kino zu zeigen, ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was hier vor sich geht. Aber wo ich es verstehe, ist so eine fictionalized Story wie Dunkirk oder sowas. Da verstehe ich zum Beispiel, warum man sich daneben dann irgendwie die... Dunkirk? Zum Beispiel. Wieso fictionalized? Diese ganzen Soldaten meine ich jetzt da, denen man folgt und so. Das ist ja alles wahrscheinlich einfach ausgedacht. Das ist ja keine, nicht basierend auf einer Biografie oder sowas. Leider Schlachtungsverlauf und so, das ist wahrscheinlich alles einigermaßen authentisch, aber man folgt dann ja Protagonisten und deren Schicksalen, die es so nicht gab. Und dann verstehe ich so, dass man sich dringend rum um die Geschichte Informationen beschaffen will, wie war das eigentlich, so die Vogelperspektive zu schaffen. Aber da haben wir es ja jetzt mit einem sehr, sehr klaren Lexikonartigen Film zu tun, der sehr geradlinig einem Wikipedia-Artikel folgt, weil es auch in der Biografie beruht und sowas. Und dann finde ich es schwierig, dass man so wirklich in den ersten zehn Minuten schon den Wikipedia-Artikel von Oppenheimer auch... Ich ertrage diese Spannung einfach nicht. Es ist so spannend, weil du einfach die einzige, einzige Geschichte durchlesen kannst, die du gerade siehst. Obwohl eine Sache gab es schon, wo ich mir dachte, das würde ich auch gerne nochmal recherchieren, habe ich da nicht gemacht, ist die Sache mit dem vergifteten Apfel. Dass Oppenheimer anscheinend irgendwie, dass er in so einer Experimentierklasse war, Physik irgendwie, krasses Wunderkind und dass irgendwie er keinen Bock auf seinen Dozenten hatte und deswegen ihm vergifteten Apfel hingestellt hat, den dann fast Niels Bohr gegessen hätte und er ihn dann davor retten muss. Wo ich mir auch denke, das würde sich Nolan doch nicht ausdenken, oder? Allein die Vorstellung zu sagen, ja, wir machen über einen der berühmtesten Physiker der Welt. Ja, und der hätte fast Nils Bohr umgebracht mit so einem Apfel, der hat so einen großen Amboss, der hat so einen Amboss über der Tür aufgehangen und dann der Erste, der reinläuft, stirbt und dann kam aber genau an dem Tag Nils Bohr und dann wollte
Nils Bohr als Erste durch die Tür und er hat gesagt,
nein, nein, ared, ared und dann hat er ihn
festgehalten und dann ist stattdessen er selber
durch den, und ich habe noch eine Idee,
Christopher, ich meine, es gibt eine Biografie.
Ich habe noch eine Idee, pass auf, und zwar jedes Meeting,
das ist eine Autobiografie, okay.
Jedes Meeting in Los Alamos, wo die dann
an der Bombe forschen, macht er eine
Zirkelspitze auf einen Stuhl.
Immer ein anderer.
Und dann setzen sie sich hin, die ganzen Schüler,
und einer setzt sich immer in die Zirkelspitze
rein. Aber warum wollen sie ihn so als
Prankster darstellen? Ich meine, er hat eine sehr
tragische Geschichte. Mir ist aufgefallen,
es ist zu tragisch. Die ganze Geschichte
ist zu tragisch, ich brauche die Lacher.
In Inception habe ich auch die ganze Lacher. Oh, da haben wir jemanden für sie. Für die Lacher, da haben wir jemanden für sie. Und zwar haben sie schon überlegt, wer Heisenberg spielen soll. Da habe ich jemanden für sie. Matthias Schweighöfer. I love this guy. He's so funny. He's so funny. I love him. Und ich meine, Heisenberg ist ein Clown, müssen wir nicht überreden. Heisenberg. Aber, ja, finde ich schonend. Ich habe mich danach sehr reingenördert in Warum haben die, Achtung, Spoiler, Nazis es nicht geschafft, die Atombäume zu bauen. Superspannend, viele Verschwörungstheorien, man kann es hier sehr viel reinlesen und so, ist alles sehr interessant. Wahrscheinlich haben es einfach nicht geschafft. Aber eine Sache fand ich dann schon komisch. Ich meine, das ist Robert Oppenheimer und dann macht er... Robert Downey Jr. spielt nicht Robert Oppenheimer. Genau. Da hast du die ganze Zeit im Kino gesessen. Ich verstehe ihn. Ich vercheck's nicht. Ich check's nicht. Ich find's doch komplizierter als Tenet. Und dann irgendwie macht er sowas von wegen, ja geil, zwei Atome, spalte ich dir kein Problem, spalte ich dir weg. Spalte ich dir no biggie. Genau. Und dann ist so das ganze Institut begeistert und ruft, Oppi, Oppi, Oppi. Und er so, psch, psch, nicht Oppi. Was? Die haben Robert Oppenheimer einfach selbstverständlicherweise, er macht was und alle, Oppi, Oppi, Oppi, und Oppenheimer so, das ist jetzt mein Spitzname, Oppi? Ich bin jetzt Oppi? Wenn ich jetzt die Riemann-Hypothese bestätige, und ich da hinstelle und sage, hier, das ist der Beweis und der ganze, ganz klar sagt, T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T-T und sie, vor allem, also dieses kollektive Spitznamen geben, auf in der Sekunde, jetzt sagen, Leute, ich wollte eins noch sagen, ich habe den Nobelpreis gewonnen, OppyP, O-P, O-P. Ich heisse Robert D. Oppenheimer Jr. Warum, aber ich meine, es ist ein guter Spitzname. Aber ich würde mich natürlich, ich hätte gerne in einem Film so einen Moment gesehen, wo er sagt so, übrigens wir müssen uns natürlich überlegen, wo wir das Plutonium herkriegen, weil wenn die Nazis ja Atombomben haben, dann geht die ganze Welt unter. Anderes Thema noch, ich habe gehört, ihr nennt mich Oppi privat. Da wollte ich noch mal kurz fragen. Wie viel Plutonium brauchen wir noch mal? Genau, wir brauchen 16 Tonnen Plutonium für den Test, genau, vier Tonnen und dann wollen wir zwei Tests. Ich hätte eine andere Idee, wie wir Plutonium generieren können. Können wir vielleicht, bevor wir darauf kommen, vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz, weil das ist habe eine neue Idee und das ist super effizient, wie wir schnell an den Themen kommen. Weil Robert, ich meine, Bob, Rob, Robbie, Bobby, ich meine, da gibt es ja so viele Möglichkeiten. Vielleicht kannst du mich nochmal kurz Schritt für Schritt durchführen durch den Prozess, wie er auf Oppi kam. Wurde Abend besprechen, irgendwie bei einem Bier oder so, aber wir wollten doch jetzt erstmal über die Plutonium sprechen. Das ist super, das ist super. Weil ich dachte einfach, wenn man...
Weil Oppi, normalerweise nimmt man ja gar nicht unbedingt einen Nachnamen, ne?
Also, weil wir haben ja jetzt Nils Bohr und den nennt ihr...
Bori.
Weil wir hatten uns bei Werner Heisenberg doch auf Werni geeinigt.
Oder, ich mein... Quanti. Was ist gegen unsere Spitze der Meinung zu werden? Nenn mich bitte Bob. Bobby? Von mir aus Bobby. Bobby Oppi? Nein! Ich spalte noch ein paar Atome jetzt. Dann ging er wieder spalten. Er ging wieder spalten. Ich treffe die immer nicht. Aber er war nicht, er hat sich aufgeregt. Jetzt regt die nicht auf. Ich treffe die nicht, die sind so klein, die Atome, Mann. Und er war nie wieder happy. Er hat die Welt gerettet. Er war nie wieder happy oppi. Aber er war nie wieder happy oppi opp Oppi. Schaut euch den Film an, schaut euch Barbie
an, schaut euch die ganzen Filme an.
Ich hab's nicht geschafft. Ich hab hier gross verkündet,
ah, Babenheimer,
geht morgens in, ob Oppi,
geht danach in, Baben, Baben.
Das heißt, du hast die Community angelogen?
Nee, nee, ich hab ja nicht gesagt, dass ich das
mache, sondern dass ich's
machen will und hab auch gesagt, das ist auch eine
coole Idee. Das ist nach wie vor eine coole Idee, es geht nur in Deutschland
nicht, weil irgendwie, zumindest in Köln,
wenn du OV-Filme guckst, läuft der
erste, erstmal laufen, drei Kinos,
die bieten dann mal so einen Film pro Tag so an
und dann muss ich ja nach den Zeiten richten.
Ich hätte ja gebraucht,
morgens 11 Uhr OV
Oppenheimer und abends
18 Uhr oder sowas OV Barbie.
No fucking chance, kannst du nicht hinkriegen in Köln. Und das war, ja, sehr ernüchternd alles. Okay. Gut, dann habe ich das jetzt. Es tut mir leid, dass du nicht genau die zwei Filme, die du schauen wolltest, genau in der Konstellation anschauen konntest, wie du es dir vorgestellt hast. Man sieht im Internet, alle leben dieses Meme und finden das dann
toll und lachen, haben eine gute
Zeit und man hört, das
ist wie so eine, das Internet ist wie
so eine Party, man liegt schon im Bett
und draußen
die WG-Party geht noch, wo man
selber nicht eingeladen ist, wo man Teil
der WG ist. Und man hört nur, ha ha ha
und denkst dir, was ist so lustig.
Ich hab noch nie einen Witz erzählt, der so gut ankam, und selber habe ich selber noch nie so laut gelacht. Ihr seid so wach, immer noch, so wach bin ich nicht mehr, wenn ich aufwache morgens. Ja, ich glaube, das ist aber auch eine wichtige soziale Lektion, ist, dass man ab einem gewissen Punkt man nicht mehr nachfragen soll, was ist denn so lustig. So, das ist, man muss ab einem gewissen Punkt diesen sozialen Zwang runterschlucken, weil es funktioniert nie. Wenn jemand, wenn du siehst eine Gruppe Leute lacht und du sagst, ha, was denn, ich hab's gerade nicht gehört. Das funktioniert nie. Du musst es runterschlucken, ich werde nie so lachen können, weil es klappt nicht. Du musst akzeptieren, dass du jetzt gerade das verpasst hast. Comedy ist im Prinzip so kompliziert, wie einom zu spalten. Da geht es um viele kleine komplexe Dinge. Einmal ist leicht, zweimal ist schwer. Genau, Plutonium zu generieren. Also es geht in grossen Mengen schwierig, Lacher zu prägen. Ich habe den Film nicht aktiv. Ich habe währenddessen den Wikipedia-Artikel nicht. Ich hätte so einen Audio-Guide gebraucht, der während des Films sagt.
Den Wikipedia-Artikel von Charlie Chaplin nebenbei offen und ich war so verwirrt, weil ich dachte, hä, falscher Artikel.
Es ist ja auch so lustig, wenn da so einen anderen Oppenheimer, Felix Oppenheimer vor mir angegriffen.
So ein SPD-Bundestagsabgeordneter aus den 80ern.
Und dann so diskutiert mit den ganzen Leuten neben sich und immer so.
Warte, ist das Willy Brandt? Nein, das ist Werner Heisenberg. Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah Warum Vater? Warum hat man sich Vater entschieden? Ziehvater, der Schwiegervater könnte man sagen. Der Schwiegervater, der so dabei war, aber jetzt nicht für die Zeugung verantwortlich war. Ziehvater. Ja, Schwibbschwager. Der Schwibbschwager der Atombombe. Werner Heisenberg ist Schwibbschwager der Atombombe. Genau der Familienstammbaum. Und Nils Bohr ist Cousin.
Ich bin der Onkel, ja der Cousin. Cousin von der Atombombe.
Ja, das ist der Familienstammbaum. Was sind denn die Kinder der Atombombe, wenn er der Vater ist? Also sozusagen der Enkel von Werner Heisenberg.
Wasserstoffbombe. Ja, gut. Können wir da mal so einen MyHeritage-mäßigen Familienstammbaum sehen? Wer ist die Tante der Atombombe? Wer ist die Mutter? Weiß mal, wer die Mutter ist. Ich weiß nicht genau. Fusionen, halt irgendwie so die Sonne oder so vielleicht. Sonne ist die Mutter der Quanten allgemein. Quanto. Quantenmechanik habe ich nicht verstanden. Ich auch nicht. Ich glaube, These, Werner Heisenberg, wäre der eigentliche Einstein, wenn wir verstehen würden, was Quantenmechanik überhaupt ist. Okay. Du meinst, Einstein ist nur deswegen so bekannt, weil er so relativ noch vergleichbar leicht zu verstehen ist? Weil man das mit geilen Anekdoten und so sich geil erzählen kann. Ja, so geilen Analogien. Da waren wir ja bei McDonalds, ne? Und dann wollten wir eigentlich bestellen. Mein Zwilling ist mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit zum anderen McDonalds gereist. Genau, also mein Zwilling war am McDrive, während ich am Schalter bestellt habe. Wir haben beide das gleiche bestelltellt. Bei Dings viel schneller. Doppelcheeseburger mit einer kleinen Pommes. Und dadurch, dass er aber sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegt hat, mit annähernder Lichtgeschwindigkeit und ich war statisch, hatte er, als er seinen Cheeseburger bekommen hat, hatte er ihn schon gegessen, als ich ihn bekommen habe. Das war die beste Zeitdilatationsanekdote, die ich jemals gehört habe. Ja, bei solchen Anekdoten, weißt du, kann man sich einfach erzählen. Und dann weiss man, ah, okay, krass, jetzt bist du vier Jahre jünger als dein Zwilling. Und das, deswegen glaube ich, feiern wir Einstein und tragen ihn auf Händen und Füssen und Oppi, nee, was habe ich gerade, wie fing das alles an? Nee, Heisenberg nicht, weil der Vater der, Zielvater der Quantenmechanien natürlich super schwierig zu verstehen ist. Ja, ja, ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich könnte es nicht erklären. Und jetzt mit KI ist natürlich auch nochmal alles, ne? Ui, das ist nochmal alles das Gottesteilchen. Draußen die Glocken sind wieder am Start. Sobald wir über die kleinsten Teilchen sprechen, gehen draußen die Glocken an. Gott sagt nein. Stopp, stopp, stopp. Gehen die Glocken eigentlich immer zur exakt gleichen Zeit im Podcast an? Könnt ihr mal gegenüberstellen, ob wir immer zur exakt gleichen Zeit aufnehmen? Ich glaube schon. Dass die Glocken immer genau zum Timecode kommen und dann könntet ihr euch auch schon darauf freuen und sagen, gleich kommen die Glocken. Hoffentlich sprechen sie es nicht wieder an. Es ist so die Frage, wo Gott eingreifen muss. Aber hier nicht so. Nierum larum. Das ist wie ein Videospiel, wenn du dann so die Einzelnen in so ein Haus gehen willst, wo der Entwickler nichts drin gebaut hat und dann so so ist es bei Gott auch so. Was ist eigentlich kleiner als Atome? Heuschrecken, habt ihr Bock auf Heuschreckenplage? Heuschrecken sind kleiner als Atome. Guckt mal, da ist eine Heuschreckenplage in Afrika. Oh nein, oh nein. Das ist euch scheißegal. Das ist euch völlig egal. Vor allem, ich habe, apropos Plage, ich hatte so eine biblische Plage zu Hause. Weil es kamen ein paar Freunde herum und ich hatte ein Wespennestproblem. Auf so ein, da ist vor den Nachbarn noch, so ein riesiger, aber es gehört auch nicht denen, sondern denen, die da vorher drin gewohnt haben, ist ein riesen Topf. So ein riesen Blumentopf steht vorne vor der Wohnung. Und da wollte ich mich eigentlich hinsetzen mit den ganzen Leuten und da ist halt ein Wespennest jetzt drin.
Und Wespennest ist naturgeschützt, man darf Wespen nicht einfach töten.
Selbst wenn, hätte ich auch nicht gewusst, wie ich das hinkriegen soll. Also habe ich das gedacht, komm, und habe es weggetragen. und dann gehe ich rein, bereite so alles vor, mache noch sauber, ziehe mich um, gehe raus und da, wo vorher noch der Topf stand und mal so eine Wespe, die mal rein und raus flog, war jetzt eine Wolke wütender Wespen, es war eine biblische Plage. Das Problem, ich habe so laut gelacht, weil das ganze Problem, was gerade ein bisschen bestand, weil da halt ein Wespen direkt neben dem Tisch ist, ist plötzlich einfach immens vergrössert
worden, weil ein wütender, und auf dem
Tisch waren so wenig so klumpen
Wespen, die dann so angefangen haben,
da ihr neues Zuhause zu bauen. Haben die sich so
schwabenartig zu noch grösseren Wespen
so zusammengetan? Genau, so einer grossen Wespe,
die so auftaucht, und ich sagte
so, boah,
du willst ja so Freunde einladen,
ja, hatte ich eigentlich vor, Sorry, ich habe euer Haus. Geht's Ihnen gut? Geht's Ihnen gut? Ah, Entschuldigung, der Raucher auch. Rauchen. Westen Rauchen. Hast du Feuer? Ja, warte. Ist doch nett, dass da mal wieder Leute vorbeikommen, oder? Ja, ich wollte gerade nur euer Nest. Warum seid ihr jetzt alle rausgekommen? Ja, wir dachten, wir kommen auch mal vorbei, weil wir ja eh schon hier lange wohnen. Ja genau. Und eigentlich dachten, dass so Nachbarschaftsding, weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wir wohnen jetzt eigentlich schon ewig nebeneinander hier. Wir haben unser Nest jetzt hier aufgeschlagen vor ein paar Wochen, aber ich habe das Gefühl, wir haben uns noch gar nicht kennengelernt. Nee genau, nichts für ungut. Ich bin Ottmar, hi. Aber hi Ottmar. Der ganze Schleuner ist Ottmar. Wir sind Ottmar. Au! Sorry, das tut mir leid. Nee, aber nichts für ungut, aber man will euch nicht so... Kommt Lisa oder was? Kommt die kleine Süße mit, die du immer schreibst oder was?
Ja, sie kommt.
Das läuft doch ganz gut oder nicht.
Kriegt ihr alles mit hier wirklich, okay?
Ich wollte nur sagen, man sieht euch nicht so gerne auf Partys.
Sorry.
Wieso das?
Weil ihr super aggressiv rumfliegt
und euch irgendwie in Limonade reinsetzt
und so.
Ja, Quatsch, was ist die Stimmung?
Ja, natürlich, wir lieben Limonade. Das ist das Problem, ihr trinkt auch Limonade. Ja, aber wir bringen euch nicht um. Da ist so ein Erdbeerkuchen eigentlich dabei. Ja, es gibt auch Erdbeerkuchen. Oh, okay. Ja, aber eben, das ist ja für uns und so, dann setzt ihr euch einfach drauf. Ja, das ist gut. Nee, und dann so deine Brüder und Schwestern setzen sich einfach und Cousins und Schwager und Tanten und ong, setzen sich einfach drauf. Okay, vielleicht willst du wirklich aufhören, so rauchen, ich verstehe nicht dieses Wasser. Komm, die ganze Familie. Nee, ich sag mal so, wir bleiben nicht ewig. Ihr steht im Gesicht dann rum und nervt, ihr seid aggressiv. Bienen sind viel entspannter und süss und so, ihr seid super aggressiv. Ja, ein bisschen langweilig, boring, so, weißt du, wir haben Bock auf Party, wir wollen tanzen, wir wollen essen, wir wollen rauchen, wir wollen rauchen, wir wollen rauchen und das ist einfach geil, ich freue mich, dass immer wieder was passiert, war ja sonst die letzten Wochen eher still, ne? Ja, ich weiß nicht so viel los. Ja, schon okay, du bist schon gut da. Aber tut dir auch mal gut, glaube ich, wieder ein paar Leute hier zu haben, oder nicht? Ja, voll. Hast du auch eine Zigarette für mich? Ja, klar. Okay, danke. Dankeschön. Was war denn da vorgestern los, Mensch? Da war ja noch nie, also, da lagst du noch lange wach im Bett, ne? Ich weiß nicht. Und dann war eine wunderbare Freundschaft entstanden zwischen dieser riesen horrormäßigen drei grossen Wespe Ottmar und mir. Und dann sind die einfach da so rum. Es war so interessant. Da habe ich mega Panik bekommen und dann habe ich den Topf wieder zurückgestellt mit dem Wespen-Nest und dann sind die alle wieder da reingegangen. Das heißt aber, die waren so irritiert, dass man ihr Wespen-Netz um drei Meter verschoben hat. Ja, verrückt, ne? Dass wenn ein Haus plötzlich um 300 Meter verschoben ist, dass du sagst. na ja, für die Wespenwelt, in der Wespenwelt. Das haben wir auch alle gesagt. In der Wespenwelt. Ah, cool, bei dir, du wärst auch nicht irritiert, wenn du nach Hause kommst und dein Haus ist verschoben worden. Doch, ich wäre irritiert. Deine Freunde sagen genau das gleiche wie ich, oder was? Ja, ehrlich gesagt haben die genau das gleiche gesagt. Sehr lustig. Ich weiss nicht, ob das jetzt ein Kompliment ist. Doch, doch, doch. Weil du könntest ja dann eigentlich statt deinen Freunden einfach mich einladen. Ja, aber du sagst ja dann ab,
du sagst, dass ein
Tag mit mir eine Woche
seines Lebens klaut.
Aber ich wäre es auch gut, wenn da so eine Nachricht kommt, so, hey Leute,
übrigens, falls ihr heute noch kommt,
Wespen würden
auch kommen. Also wir haben Wespen
da und also
Man sagt ja bei einem Bienenschwarm, der Bienen,
die Wesp. Die Wesp ist auch dabei. Ist auch dabei. Wer ist die Wesp? Ist das wie so eine von deinen Tinder-Freunden? Nee, das ist ein Meta-Organismus aus einem Schwarm Wespen. Genau. Frau Wesp kommt vorbei. So eine gemeinsame, sehr intelligente Da kam vielleicht das Ökosystem,
so ein Biom, das sozusagen ein...
Kannst du auch für ein Biome einzuladen,
wenn wir abhängen?
Kannst du auch für die Taranteln neulich waren auch
fucking nervig. Ich habe immer
so das Bedürfnis, wenn
ab und zu mal jemand zu mir kommt, will ich immer
vorwarnen, so. Dir ist schon klar,
dass mein Abfluss aktuell
nicht funktioniert, dass ich quasi in der Kiste... wirklich, ich lebe in der Kiste. Okay, ist die Kiste groß? Wie gross ist sie? Ja, wir sind, ja, wir sind wie so ein Bierkasten. Okay, kein Problem. Da defikiere ich rein und also meine ganzen, okay, das kenne ich nicht. Naja, macht er meinen Körpermüll quasi.
Ah, okay. So wie Dosen, Dosen und so?
Nee.
Ah, okay. Verstehe.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, und ja, also die Sonne ist auch echt blöd bei mir.
Also ab sechs Uhr dreissig ist volle Sonne im Gesicht.
Kein Problem, ey. Solange du keine Wespen machst, alles gut.
So, und jetzt tatsächlich unterm Dach sind dann jetzt Wespen gesichtet worden. Lass aber zu mir in die Kiste. Okay. Yes. Yes. Ich muss nicht aufräumen. Es ist also nicht komplett umsonst, dass ich in einer absoluten, kompletten Bullshit-Höhle lebe. So kann ich Leute zumindest abb zumindest abblocken ist es völlig okay gamescom ist ein
thema für dich gar nicht kommt das bald gamescom kommt und schluckt köln bist du bist du am bist du arcade mode oder bist du dran hast du ein joystick hast du ein joypad oder fun fun meter habe ich fun ab hast du hast du keinen spaß ich habe kein video heisst jagst du dem highscore Keine Games, keine Highscores.
Weil ich bin ja Gamer, ne, also ich krieg's ja nicht los, ne.
Agro Range. Ich krieg's ja nicht los.
Agro-Range. Ich krieg's nicht los, ich bin Gamer.
Open World Map.
Open World First Person Map.
Leveling.
Ja?
Shooter Range, The Range, Agro Range.
Und welche Spiele zockst du dann so?
First Person Ranges, Agro Ranges.
Okay, cool.
Drauf Vogelperspektiven.
Okay, also kompetitiv oder solo oder eher so?
Aufbauspiele.
Aufbaushooter?
Im First Person Mode.
Okay. Auf Hard gestellt, nicht Anfänger, sondern Tough Guys gestellt. Okay, cool, ja. Ja, und dann wird geshootet mit der Rifle zum Beispiel. Und dann noch In-App-Käufe. Oh ja, auch cool. Ich bin an den Bärzern, die ich kenne, weisst du, was für einen Blick ich auf Games habe. Ich habe so Artikel über Games gelesen, wo Thema ist. Du hast einen Sternenartikel über Gaming gelesen und du hast dir jedes Wort gemerkt. In-App-Käufe, Microtransactions, Downloadable Content, Gratifications durch Sammler, Massive, multiplayer, online, role-playing,
gaming,
chair.
Ja, egal.
Ernst, sehen wir uns, oder was?
Ich hätte tatsächlich wieder Lust
auf Konsolenspiele.
Ich hätte tatsächlich Lust auf
nochmal irgendwie so Breathhead Redemption
oder sowas. Dinge, wo ich so mein eigenes
kleines Leben leben kann. Und was ich dann immer mache, ist, ich kaufe mir dann schöne Kleider. Das mag ich immer gerne. Ich kauf mir dann, also ich grade mich gerne als Figur ab. Cooles Pferd, coole Klamotten, und auch dann rum. Cooler Hut. Cooler Hut, wir deuten zugehaudit und so. Das Das mag ich ganz gern. So dann diese ganzen Storys und so auch spannend. Ich ärgere mich ein bisschen, weil alle empfehlen, wenn immer so Last of Us zu spielen, weil das so eine, weil es ist wie ein Film zu gucken, aber halt noch immersiver und so. Es klingt alles perfekt, ich möchte die Zeit nicht reinstecken. Das Last of Us Spiel ist so, als würdest du die Serie spielen quasi. Als würdest du die Serie spielen? Das ist schon ganz cool eigentlich. Ich wurde verarscht von meinen Enkeln. Die haben mir Last of Us angemacht und einen Controller in den Fernseher gesteckt. Und ich habe es nach 16 Stunden, habe ich erst verstanden, dass ich nicht, weil ich dachte, oh, die Controller istisch und so. Und immer wenn ich, erst dachte ich, immer wenn ich auf X drücke, wird geschnitten im Bild. Ja. Also so, und dass man dann die Perspektive wählt, habe ich erst nicht verstanden und so und dann schießen war auch mega schwierig und so. Und nach 16 Stunden habe ich dann so, bei der vorletzten Folge, habe ich erst verstanden, dass mein Kontrolle nicht angeschlossen war, sondern ich eine Serie geguckt habe. Das war so dumm, aber... Ach Mensch, aber du hattest Spaß zumindest in der Zeit. Voll, voll. Es war richtig immersiv. Und ich dachte mir, krass, das ist wie einen Film zu gucken, wie einen langen Film zu gucken. Das ist quasi wie eine Serie, das Spiel. Und dachte ich irgendwann so, weil ich habe sehr selten auf R2 hinten gedrückt, dass immer wenn ich R2 drücke, die Credits kommen. Das war so zweimal hat es ungefähr gepasst. Ich habe bis Ende nicht genau die von Scholes nicht verstanden.
Nee, war cool und so.
Aber war wie gesagt ein Prank.
Seitdem zweifle ich an mir und meiner Gesundheit.
Ich mag das auch, wie es so von mittelalter, antike Zeiten, so ja, irgendwie respektiere deine Alten,
irgendwie respect your elders zu,
wir pranken einfach die komplett durch.
Wir machen einfach schön Bundesliga an
und sagen, ob er das als FIFA spielen kann. Und dann lachen wir uns kaputt. Das habe ich mir mal erzählt, glaube ich, aber mein Opa hat wirklich mal zu uns gesetzt, wie mein Cousin und ich Fußball gespielt haben und es stand so 6 zu 0 Dortmund gegen Dortmund. Und er hat gesagt, krass, führen die Borussen sechs zu null.
Die Borussen. Ja, das war alles einfach. Also es war fast vielleicht doch was, Dortmund gegen die deutsche Nationalmannschaft, was Albenes oder Deutschland gegen Argentinien, nee, Dortmund gegen Argentinien. Naja, und er hat dann gedacht, krass, die spielen, weil die Grafik wurde immer besser und sowas und Opa immer älter.
Ja.
Und dann ist es völlig okay. Aber es ist auch gemein, die Älteren zu pranken. Lass uns lieber pflegen statt pranken.
Ja, oder vielleicht eine Gemeinschaftlichkeit, sowohl pranken als auch pflegen, so ein Hybridsystem.
Nicht nur über sie lachen, sondern mit ihnen über sie lachen. Genau, so ein Alten wo einfach auch den ganzen Tag geprankt wird. Einfach so ganz nackt Pranks. Prankenheim, genau. Prankenheim. Prankenheimer. Ich habe gedacht, ich würde auch gerne einen Film machen, wo ich einfach so eine Biografie verfilme. Welche Biografie würdest du am liebsten verfilmen? Welcher, welchem Leben würdest du dir annehmen? Ich nehme jetzt mich mal raus. Also du brauchst jetzt nicht mich sagen, ich würde dich jetzt einfach, Ash Ketchum? Ash Ketchum, die Ash Ketchum-Autobiografie. Die Auto... Ich bin der Beste, den es jemals gab. Ich schnapp sie mir alle. Ich schnapp sie mir alle. Das sind ja die berühmten ersten Sätze der Ash Ketchum-Autobiografie. Ich schnapp sie mir alle. Ne,napp sie mir alle. Das sind die berühmten ersten Sätze der Ash-Catch im Autobiografie.
Ich schnapp sie mir alle. Ne, das weiss ich nicht genau. Werden finde ich spannend. Es gibt ein paar spannende Characters. Das waren, also, ich war jetzt im Urlaub eine Zeit lang mit Freunden und das war eines der Spiele, die wir gespielt haben. Warum dieses Zeit lang? Warum lässt es so vage, wie lange das war? Eine Zeit lang? Eine Weile. Und wir haben witzige Spiele gespielt, zum Beispiel wir haben Pokémon-Songs gehört und haben uns gefragt, ab wann ist der Song Pokémon-Song? Ah, spannend. Also weil die Songs fangen an, ja, hör auf dein Herz und du geh deinen Weg bis zum Ende, du trägst ein Geheimnis tief in dir und halt einfach solche Sachen, bis irgendwann dann Schiggi Ratfrass Pokémon-Sanda Okay, jetzt ist es ein Pokémon-Song. Bis jetzt hätte man es noch ganz normal anhören können. Wie geht nochmal der andere Song, dieser super epische Intro-Song? Pokémon flieg, flieg! Nein, nein, nein, ich meine nicht den. So, da ist relativ schnell klar. Ich meine den, wo die alle vorne reinlaufen, die Dinos. Ich schnapp sie mir. Wie heißt denn der Song nochmal? Wie geht denn denn der am Anfang noch mal? Der ist so geil. Und der ist auch im Prinzip so, ich will der Allerbeste sein, geht, wie keiner vor mir war, geht, mega merkwürdig. Wenn Tina Turner singt, I wanna be the very best, ja okay, sie sagt auch Simply the best, also ich meine sie jetzt schon, ist eine gute Frage. I wanna simply be the best. Keiner vor mir war. Das Pokémon, um zu verstehen. Sehr schnell klar. Diese Kraft verleiht. Da sagt dann Celine Dion, Moment mal, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Was singe ich hier für einen Song? Aber tauscht mal Pokémon, das Wort Pokémon, gegen Liebe. Okay. So, und schon ist es einfach
nur ein megacooler, Liebe die gelbe Edition.
So ein Matthias Reim-artiger Song.
Okay. Ich will der Allerbeste
sein, wie keiner vor mir
war.
Die Liebe, um zu verstehen,
was sie diese Kraft
verleiht. Liebe,
Liebe,
komm, schnapp sie dir. Ja. Geht. In allem, was ich auch tue, Liebe, du mein bester Freund, komm, retten wir die Welt. Es geht. Super. Kein Problem. Wenn man das so tauscht und so, dann denkt man, was verleiht der Kraft, was verleiht der Liebe Kraft. Und dann ergibt es wieder ein bisschen Sinn. Aber du, ihr habt recht, es ist auch die Frage, wann wird ein Bond-Song ein Bond-Song?
Ja.
Weil da wird nicht die ganze Zeit von James Bond, James Bond, also nicht Teil der Lyrics.
James Bond.
Fun Fact, kein Bond-Song beinhaltet den Namen James Bond.
Oh.
Und trotzdem sind es alle Bond-Songs und auch erkennlicher als Bond-Songs.
Erkenntlich, okay. Du könntest einen Bond-Song erkennen am Song. Ja. Ich gebe dir eine Playlist und einer dieser Songs ist ein Bond-Song und du musst mir sagen, welcher der Bond-Song ist. Der Bond-Song, ja, gib mir den Bond-Song, ich rette den Bond-Song. Guess the Bond-Song. Bob the Bond-Song. Ja, werde ich hinkriegen, glaube ich. Ach ja. Auch gut, weil die, ja. Ich meine, es geht auch um Waffen und ... Ich würde, ich habe mir überlegt, wenn ich dieses Album höre, ich hätte einfach Bock auf ein Pokémon-Musical. Aber jetzt ist es natürlich rechtlich schwierig, aber kann ich jetzt einfach so ein bisschen das ändern. Also, dass ich ... Wir haben Pokémon-Musical zuhause, und dann geht es halt um Mikachu. Genau, Mikachu und es sind nicht Pokémon, sondern Bokemon. Also es sind Bucketmonster. Eimermonster. Du hast nicht die Pokébälle, sondern Poké-Eimer. Bucketmon. Und dann so hast du so kleine Eimer an deinem Gürtel hängen und da in jedem Eimer ist so eine Flüssigkeit drin, nach der Farbe des Elements, und dann schüttest du den kleinen Eimer aus und daraus entsteht dann Shiggy oder Flamara oder was auch immer. Ja, genau, genau, Shoggy und Shaggy. Hi, Mr. Bombastic, hi, ich bin Shiggy. Sag mal, ist das die richtige Pokémon-Version, die wir da für wenig Geld gekauft haben? Sag mal, immer wenn die Oma aus Kroatien ... Wasserattacke, Wasserattacke. Moment mal, ist das wirklich Nintendo? Tenendo? Tenendo. Das ist von Tenendo? Bucketmon. Bucketmon, jetzt im Handel. Kann ich mir mal gut vorstellen. Aber würdet ihr Bucketmon das Musical sehen? Und dann direkt, es gibt weder Bucketmon, es gibt nur Bucketmon das Musical. Ich liebe das sehr. Genau, es ist ein Franchise, das nur ein Musical hat. Bucketmon das Musical, einfach offensichtlich lizenzrechtlich schwierig. Und dann gibt es auch das Anwalt Bucketmon, das dann in der Mitte des Musicals kommt und so seine Ballade hat so. Ich habe auf meinem Tisch die verschiedenen Versionen und muss sie noch vergleichen. Ein Akzent ist hier und muss sie noch vergleichen. Ein Akzent auf dem E noch drauf, ist das ein anderer Name? Und dann musst du aber die Melodie immer verändern. Ist das ein anderer Name? Damit du nicht in Schwierigkeiten kommst. Alle Songs sind so hässlich, weil es Pokémons, offensichtliche Pokémon-Songs sind, wo die Melodie zwischendurch viel zu hoch. Einfach eine Note ist viel zu hoch. Was ganz andere sind, ja, finde ich super. Ich würde es mir angucken, allein weil du es machst. Ich glaube, es ist ein reines, ist es ein Virtual Reality Musical?
Ich war ja auch, ja, können wir abkürzen die Story, aber ich war ja auch in Bayreuth beim Richard Wagner Festspielen. Dann, dann, dann, dann, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, und jetzt habt ihr euch Bayreuth gespart. Das ist es im Grunde. Bayreuth das Musical und da gab es jetzt auch zum ersten Mal, wurde jetzt der Passiv, weil da habe ich leider nicht gesehen, weil das ist die neue, in die Richtung ist, wo ich meine Schlechtkarten für. Und da wurde jetzt mit Virtual Reality Brillen zum ersten Mal gearbeitet. Echt? Ja, dass Leute im Publikum dann so VR-Brillen haben, was natürlich total geil ist. Alle? Nicht alle, weil es gab auch, glaube ich, dann nur 600 Stück oder sowas und es passen 2000 Leute das Publikum, aber 600 Leute hatten dann halt so VR-Brillen auf und haben dann halt das Stück gesehen und dann gab es so Augmented Reality Style Dinge, die zusätzlich noch passieren auf der Bühne über die Brille. Wahnsinnig fantastisch. Hattest du eine Brille oder nicht? Ich war nicht im Pass, weil er hatte keine Brille auf. Ich hatte eine VR-Brille auf in der Götterdämmerung.
Aber gut, die war aus und ich habe nichts gesehen, das war ein grosses... Das war interessant, weil das ist die Zugang von Theater. Das ist ja viel billiger, glaube ich schon. Leider ja. Warum ist es billiger? Ja, klar. Dass dann keine Schauspieler auf der Bühne stehen, sondern alle haben nur die VR-Brille auf. Du hast eine VR-Brille auf und du sparst dir einfach riesengroße Bühnenbilder oder sowas.
Du kannst ja wahnsinnig viel einfach dazu digital ändern. Ja, aber du kommst dir halt auch extrem
dumm vor, wenn du vor der
Aufführung noch miteinander redest, oder?
Also dann sagst du, ja, also im zweiten
Akt bin ich echt gespannt, wie sieht das mit sehr groß jetzt.
Man sieht sich nicht, weil beide haben diese riesen
Bühnen auf. Und beide drehen sich zur Seite um und die Brillen
stoßen aneinander, so klong, klong.
Das hört sich so eine Kettenreaktion aus.
Allein im Publikum. Dominoday. Dominoday. Das ist, glaube ich, die Zukunft. Das ist für dich die Zukunft des Theaters. Nicht für mich, ich glaube, es ist einfach eine Zukunft. Eine mögliche Zukunft. Eine mögliche Zukunft des Jahres. Die Frage ist, biegen wir jetzt gemeinsam in diese gemeinsame Zukunft ab oder lassen wir es hinter uns? Ich finde es spannend. Meine Idee war dann, ich würde gerne auch mal irgendwie so eine Ringoper inszenieren, muss man wahrscheinlich alle machen, aber ich will nur die Wahlküre und dann kommen die Wahlküren, so fliegen sie über das Publikum.
Ah ja, okay. Und dann kriegen sie dir so Wasser ins Gesicht gespritzt.
Ja genau.
Und der Stuhl vibriert.
Reingold am Anfang, die ganzen Reintöchter-Szenen.
Weia, weia, woge die Welle.
Die ganze Zeit boom, ins Wasser gespritzt.
Das ganze Publikum auf der so Ü-60, Ü-70 Publikum, was dann so durch die Gegend geschleubelt wird auf den 4D-Sitzen. Ich reisse, meine erste Amtshandlung ist aus dem ganzen UNESCO-Welterbe, Opernhaus, erstmal diese ganzen Drecksdinger und dann so 4D-Sitze reinbauen. 4D-Sitze mit Elektroschocks, einfach Komplett durchgeschüttelt. Das braucht Wagner heute. Hat er nicht gesagt, Kinder schaffen Neues.
Wahrscheinlich meinte er das. Baut mein Theater voll mit 4D-Sitzen.
Mit 4D und Popcorn.
Und Popcorn draussen und da wird vollgespritzt Stromschocks und VR-Brillen, dass alle bei den Walküren ritten.
Die Walküren fliegen so durchs Publikum, das fände ich schon ziemlich gut.
Die landen auf der Bühne und dann beginnen die da.
Also das wäre, ne, call me. Just give me a call. und VR-Brillen, dass alle bei den Walküren ritten. Die Walküren fliegen so durchs Publikum, das finde ich schon ziemlich cool, landen auf der Bühne und dann
beginnen die da. Also das wäre
Call me, just give me a call.
Kannst du deine Handynummer nochmal nennen?
1 7
8 3
4 9
4. Okay, alles klar, danke, dann ruft ihn gerne an und dann wirst du Bescheid. Was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ich habe meine Nummer genommen und dann ich habe hinten eine Zahl nach oben korrigiert und mal die rinderzahl nach unten korrigiert, also meine Nummer Nachbarn. Und dann habe ich den jeweils bei WhatsApp geschrieben. Habe geschrieben Hello Number Neighbor, was geht? Und dachte, vielleicht entsteht eine wahnsinnig coole Geschichte, eine tolle Freundschaft oder mehr. Entschuldigung, hier ist das Gasamt Köln. Haben Sie ein Problem mit Ihrer Gasleitung? Hi Nummer Nachbar, ich habe eine Nummer, ich bin die 50. Hallo, hier ist das Gasleitungsinstandsetzungsamt. Ja genau, ich habe hinten die 50, ich habe die 51. Deswegen wollte ich mal Hallo sagen. Haben Sie Probleme mit Ihrer Gasleitung? Nee, nee, ich bin nur ein Number-Neighbor. Bitte melden Sie sich nur, wenn Sie ein Gasleck oder ein Problem mit Ihrer Gasleitung haben. Hashtag Number-Neighbor, Number-Neighbor. Bitte, wir müssen uns darum kümmern, Gaslecks sofort zu identifizieren und zu schliessen, okay? Wenn Sie kein Gasproblem haben, bitte melden Sie sich nicht bei dieser Nummer. Okay. Ich versuche die eine, ich versuche die 449 jetzt. Hi, Number-Neighbor!edenkstätte Auschwitz, ja, hallo, guten Tag. Möchten Sie mit einer Schulklasse vorbeikommen? Warum hat das Gedenkzentrum Auschwitz eine Handynummer? Warum haben die keinen Festnetzanschluss? Warum haben die nur eine Handynummer auf dich? Warum ist das mein Nummernachbar?? Können wir Ihnen helfen? Sie sind ja auch bei der Telekom, also.
Ja, natürlich.
Nee, ist alles gut. Zwei Erwachsenen-Tickets bitte.
Okay.
Jesus. Jetzt brauche ich jemanden, mit dem ich da hingegangen habe.
Hi, Gasamt!
Nur eine Frage, komische Frage, aber wir haben es ja gerade so gut verstanden.
Nee, aber ich habe zwei Tickets.
Oh Gott, nein.
Das ist auch so das demütigste, wenn man eine Kinokarte bestellt, so online reserviert,
und dann ist immer als Default schon eingestellt zwei Personen.
Und ich drücke dann immer noch einmal runter auf eine Person.
Und es ist so, deutlicher kann man es eigentlich nicht sagen. Das ist gar nicht vorgesehen, was du hier machst. Ich will Oppi einfach genießen. Ja, man will Oppi einfach reinsetzen und dann den Wikipedia-Artikel offen haben, um das ganze Kino zu beleuchten. Und mitlesen, so wie man so die Partitur mitliest. Und jetzt kommt der traische Konflikt. Jetzt kommt der So sitzt du immer in den Opern, liest du das Libretto, liest du dabei. Jetzt Jubo! Und das war Gott. Nice. Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören an dieser Stelle. Ich wünsche euch alle eine fantastische Woche, Florentin, du auch. Ich möchte explizit auch nochmal Viktoria und Leo grüssen, die das Intro bereitgestellt haben. Ich wünsche auch. Und ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine ganz schöne Woche. Wir sind wieder da. Nee, ich bin jetzt ein paar Mal weg. Ach so, okay. Aber es findet bei den Stadt... Wir finden Ersatz, kein Problem. Einen Tag in der Woche finden wir, wo wir uns treffen können und dieses lustige kleine Projekt aufrechterhaltenusiasmus einfach wie selbstverständlich, Ich dachte, das wäre... Du weisst doch genau, und wir haben gesagt, wofür ist dieser grosse Knopf, ich sage ihn direkt einfach nicht drauf.
Niemals, sorry, sorry. Und jetzt hat Stefan voller Enthusiasmus einfach wie selbstverständlich.
Ich dachte, das wäre unser Stahlknopf.
Wir wissen auch nicht genau, was wir uns ausgelöst haben.
Nee, komm, wir machen es wie immer.
Okay, alles klar.
Bucklopp.
Gut, wir heben ab, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.
It's the worst. Ich ab, buckle ab. Gut, wir heben ab, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.